en partance pour l'ohio et le texas
donald trump ne devait pas se faire trop
d'illusions sur l'accueil réservé dans
deux villes meurtries majoritairement
démocrate
dès son arrivée à dayton où la fusillade
a fait neuf victimes
le comité d'accueil s'est fait très
vocal sur son chemin quelques dizaines
de manifestants étaient là pour exprimer
leur rejet des politiques du président
et les relents racistes lors de ces
rassemblements partisans à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
voici les images fournies par l'équipe
de communication du président tout
sourire avec le personnel un message
très contrôlée car aucune caméra de
médias n'était en effet autorisés à
filmer la scène
ce politicien démocrate reconnaît que
donald trump et sa femme ont fait ce
qu'il fallait faire tenter de
réconforter les blessés
avec sa population majoritairement
d'origine mexicaine
el paso avait un message semblable pour
le président
yoann a droit comme ils disent comme eu
quelques manifestations pour dénoncer sa
visite en ces temps douloureux mais rien
pour l'empêcher de jouer son rôle de
président de tous les américains
le rôle de consolateur en chef pendant
ce temps ses critiques démocrate
affûtent leurs couteaux politique en
france
joe biden ne croit pas à la sincérité de
donald trump
quand il dit condamner les actes et
propos des suprémacistes blancs
plus tôt en journée le président lançait
quelques suggestions pour le contrôle
des armes à feu
il propose encore de renforcer la
vérification des antécédents surtout
chez les personnes souffrant de
problèmes mentaux mais bien trop peu et
trop tard selon le démocrate better work
will be in a country ce pays dit il
refuse d'adopter des lois pour éliminer
la violence par les armes à feu
le constat est encore plus tranché pour
la mairesse de dayton en ohio qui
partisanerie mise de côté n'espère plus
rien face à l'inaction légendaire des
congrès successifs mêlant démocrates et
républicains après chaque fusillade
meurtrière viennent toujours les
promesses de réduction de la violence
par les armes à feu des souhaits
politique évoquée dans l'impulsion du
moment mais qui ne débouchent jamais se
rend reserrement concret des lois
ces deux dernières tueries ne feront
probablement pas exception à la règle
ici frédéric arnold de radio canada
el paso au texas